musicien de talent et jouera les œuvres
majeures de son complice George apergis
sur les drôles de machine musical de
Claudine Brahem il sera le 17 mai en
concert au théâtre de 50 ansline avec
Louis Sclavis voici Jean-Pierre Drouet
dans le kiosque les machines musicales
c'est
une c'est un
travail auquel s'est livré Claudine
Braham pendant une vingtaine d'années à
peu près
euh c'est c'est c'est un travail qui a
commencé avec George apergis il avait il
avait l'idée d'une pièce de théâtre
musical avec trois personnages on était
arrivé à la conclusion que ça serait
bien d'avoir des bruits à disposition
mais des bruits pas des bruits sur sur
ordinateur pas avec un échantillonneur
un truc comme ça mais des vraiment des
des des objets qui fassent du bruit donc
on a demandé à Claudine
que je venais d'épouser euh si elle se
sentait si elle sentait capable et
inspiré par l'idée de fabriquer des
instruments sont des espèces de pianos
avec des touches énormes des pianos
préhistorique pergis a écrit pour ces
pour ces trois instruments là et puis
après pour à la suite de ça pour
d'autres créations de lui il a encore
demandé à Claudine des des nouveaux
instruments et puis d'autres
compositeurs s'y sont mis le pou
d'instruments s'est augmenté petit à
petit on est arrivé on a une
cinquantaine d'instruments l'idée de
parcours c'était un peu de montrer
comment ces instruments là pouvaient
fonctionner dans les mains d'un d'un
musicien
[Musique]
professionnel
parcours parce que c'est une une espèce
de parcours à travers une collection
d'instruments le plateau est couvert de
de machines de tout genre il il y a une
vingtaine de machines sur le plateau et
je je vais deun à l'autre et c'est un
parcours aussi dans l'œuvre de d'apergis
parce qu'il y a des il y a des des
pièces d'une d'une certaine année don il
y a les trois premières évidemment mais
il y a des pièces d'autres années et
puis a des pièces que j'ai adapté
moi-même pour les
machines une des caractéristiques
d'ergis surtout à cette époque cétait
écrivait des textes musicaux plutôt avec
langages imaginair des fausses des
combinaisons de de de voyell qui qui
prenaent à l'intérieur de de mots réels
ce qui fait qu'on entend des chosees on
pourrait croire qu'on comprend quelque
chose mais en fait les mots ne
signifient pas mais ils sont familiers
j'ai pris pas mal de ces textes que j'ai
orchestré que j'ai aménagé avec les
autres machines c'est aussi un parcours
un peu dans mon dans mon évolution
[Musique]
musicale
pour ce spectacle j'ai invité j'ai
invité Louis clavis parce que il avait à
l'époque on avait fait une on avait fait
la musique pour une pièce de François
Verret une
chégraphe qui à cette époqueel
travaillit beaucoup avec Claudine Brahem
comme scénographe et elle nous avait
fabriqué des des des machines et avait
fabriqué pour esclaviste une grosse
machine vraiment une grosse machine
assez complexe avec plein de mécanismes
à pédal pour qu'il puisse jouer des
instruments tout en jouant de la jouant
de la la clarinette il en a fait une
chose qu'il appelle le
concerto
[Musique]
il est seul sur cette machine avec la
présence d'étien bulletinger qui est qui
est à côté qui a mis des micros partout
puis qui reprend un peu en live le ce
que
fait ce que fait esclavis développe crée
des des univers Honor derrière esclavist
c'est là il se démène comme un fou il
actionne des des des pédales des il fait
tourner des des choses c'est tout en
continuant à jouer c'est c'est un
spectacle
[Musique]
formidable et maintenant un nouveau
sujet de la rédaction c'est beau ces
couleurs de printemps là je
j'adore ce visage Royal c'est celui de
Madame ellisabeth sœur du roi Louis X et
bellesœur de Marie Antoinette une
exposition inédite du conseil général
des ivelines propose de se plonger dans
l'univers de cette princesse à travers
130 œuvres à peu près la moitié sont des
prês du château de Versailles qui est
partenairire de l'exposition beaucoup
d'œuvres sont inédites elles ont
appartenus aux dames de Madame
ellisabeth ce sont des cadeaux que la
princesse a fait à ses amis et ces
cadeaux ont été conservés dans les par
les descendants donc dans ses familles
et n'ont jamais été présentés pour la
plupart
les pièces les plus étonnantes les
bijoux que la princesse confectionnait à
partir de ses propres cheveux pour les
offrir en gage d'amitié dans la demeure
du domaine de Madame ellisabeth on
découvre l'ambiance de l'époque le
mobilier et la décoration si
emblématique comme dans ce salon turc où
une chaise en toile de jouie verte
appelée voyeuse permettait à la
princesse de s'appuyer pour jouer
l'expérience des visiteurs est aussi
sensorielle des extraits de harpe et
aussi des bornes de ur rose fleurs
d'oranger ou chocolat chaud et des
échantillons de matériaux et tissus à
toucher des modèles de caraco jupes et
autres tenues à la mode sont présenté
dont l'unique robe en chemise préservée
en France après ça la visite se poursuit
à l'extérieur avec une déambulation dans
le jardin thématique
reconstitué voit bien cette barrière de
de d'agrume qui ferme le jardin un petit
peu champêtre et et anglochinois on va
dire anglais
un petit peu libre et le jardin des
humeurs des humeurs de princesse soigné
à l'époque grâce à des plantes
aromatiques en peau quand le roi venait
visiter les jardins il fallait que tout
soit parfait donc le plus simple c'était
d'enlever une plante et de la remettre
par un pot ça faisait qu'un trou ça
évité de pétiner dans les massifs
l'exposition se termine dans l'orangerie
sur le destin tragique de la petite
fille du roi Louis XV elle est
emprisonnée et meurt en martyre
guillotiné en
et encore quelques dates à retenir avant
votre cours de cuisine javanaise le 21
mai vous pourrez rire de bon cœur avec
10 ans de mariage à la salle jacqubrê à
Montini le Bretonneux et du 21 au 24 mai
vous pourrez déguster le savoureux
complètement toqué au théâtre de
SaintQuentin en Eveline du 21 au 25 mai
un petit hublot de ciel sera à découvrir
dès 2 ans à la Maison de la poésie de
Saint-Quentin en Eveline des dates que
vous pouvez retrouver sur internet aux
adresses qui s'affichent et cette
semaine sur le 3
wkios.sk.fr vous pouvez gagner du 30
avril au 6 mai TR fois de place pour
Dick anard au Scarab alors bon spectacle
à tous et à
bientôt